there are more and more electric powered
ferries in the world at least for short
distances across rivers or small lakes
but one of the big problems with them is
that the batteries required are massive
and expensive a ferry not only has to
move something the size of a building
but it's got to push the water out of
the way too so you need far more energy
than something like an electric car
electric ferries would be a lot easier
to run if you could just you know plug
them into the mains so that's what the
randers fjords ferry in Denmark does it
has 350 meters of hardened waterproof
electrical cable rolled up on a drum one
end is connected to the ferry the other
end is plugged into the electrical grid
just there and as we set off all the
power for the motors will be coming from
the shore founded
this is
the most surprising thing for me is just
how quiet this Ferry is there's no
diesel motor churning away and you might
be thinking okay what if something snags
on the cable well this was already a
cable guided Ferry even before it was
electric cable ferries are pretty common
around the world in places like this
Channels with strong currents or shallow
Waters instead of being pushed by
propeller the boat pulls itself across
by latching onto two cables laid across
the riverbed there's not much boat
traffic around here and there are
already clear rules for how to navigate
around cables like that basically don't
pass while the Ferry's in motion is
foreign
boats are obviously going to be limited
to a few situations and the biggest fuel
burners are still going to be the
massive world traveling container ships
but this does feel like one more step in
the right direction